team liquid didn't start as a pitch to
investors
it wasn't hatched in the mind of a
marketing executive or designed to sell
ads
it didn't have any sponsors hoodies or a
team specific hashtag it's team liquid
and that's what it means to them
over 20 years of history some of its
fans became players and eventually some
of its players became owners they are
the only team to lift the trophy back to
back to back to back and they are the
best team north america has ever
produced but the team never lost the
things that had made it unique and it
held on to the people who had helped it
evolve even as the entire esports
landscape shifted dramatically
there's no other story like it in
esports this is the story of team liquid
[Applause]
[Music]
in the year 2000 the liquid clan in
starcraft brood war was one of a million
user-created affiliations for victor
nazgul goosens who became leader of the
liquid clan it was something that could
let him choose the kinds of players he'd
play with the players
that joined team liquid they were all
best in class like top in the world like
great great players but they were also
great people there was a group of folks
that had a lot of respect for each other
didn't really trash talk
just kind people and and that was really
important for us but liquid became more
than a clan in the early 2000s they
launched their website teamliquid.net
here fans could discuss the latest news
in both korean and foreign starcraft
competitions on their forums i don't
even remember how old i was exactly
maybe around like 11 12 13 and liquid
was always the main hub in the terms of
like reddit is like a hub for discussion
for a lot of people teamliquid.net was
that hub and they were always like the
pinnacle of like starcraft 2 esports for
me as like a you know as a foreigner as
they call it in the starcraft 2 scene
and as the website approached 10 years
of following starcraft in 2010 and the
second game in the series neared release
they became a sponsored team their first
sponsorships in 2010 gave them pro-team
status and even allowed them to send
players to korea where one of them made
semi-finals at gsl the deepest a
foreigner had ever gone we should be
seeing the gg anytime now yeah this game
is done i am so proud of jinro i'm sure
you all are as well we have a non-korean
in the final ggo and that is it
jin row moves on to the round of four
he's so happy
2012 was an important year for esports
counter-strike global offensive release
dota 2 and league of legends were in
full swing and the idea of an esports
organization growing alongside those
games made some obvious sense but liquid
did something different sure they signed
a dota 2 squad but at a time when many
premier organizations were looking to
newer games they chose to enter super
smash bros melee that 2014 entry to
smash bros saw liquid sign ken and kdj
which at the time was a huge commitment
but things were about to change
dramatically not only for liquid but for
the history of esports as a whole
in 2015 the north american lcs had a
problem one of their teams was sponsored
by curse a multimedia company that also
ran fan sites and notably a voice over
ip service called curse voice but a
partnership to promote curse voice with
multiple other lcs teams was deemed
impossible while the company fully
sponsored their own team and so in
january 2015 team curse merged with
liquid taking the liquid name giving
them a spot in the nalcs and crucially
bringing on steve liquid 112 r hansen a
former player turned director of esports
for curse when i reached out to victor
that first conversation i remember i did
a call with him and i was like hey so
i'd love to chat with you about possibly
merging
our companies together and he's like who
are you
[Laughter]
unlike the realistic and analytical
nazgul steve was creative and
idea-focused i i feel like steve
wakes up with probably like 20 new ideas
every single day um and i like to take
my time and filter through them we're
just very different people you know we
make decisions differently we process
information differently we lead
differently
and so i felt like that in of itself was
the fabric of building a great
leadership team besides a new
partnership at the top the merger gave
liquid access to league of legends a
fast-growing discipline that had global
appeal and seemed poised to take over
the esports space but it also reinforced
their investment in a game they already
supported smash the merger meant that
two of curses smash players chill and
dude and hungrybox were now on team
liquid i felt good i felt good because i
knew of the size of the org i knew their
legacy in starcraft and i also knew that
quite simply put there were much more
mainstay in the esports scene hungrybox
was making waves in smash he was one of
the five gods known for his jigglypuff
play and his competitive intensity in
2015 dreamhack winter would play host to
a melee tournament and hungrybox had a
feeling it was his to win there was just
one problem he needed liquid's help they
were willing to work with me a lot of
things that i needed mainly the main
risk they took was like listen my buddy
lewis here crunch i know it's gonna
sound like a gamble would you mind
paying half his ticket and i'll meet you
guys halfway to go to sweden with me for
dreamhack winter and they steve i
remember i'll never forget steve said
juan
do you need him to win
and will you guys win if he goes and i
said yes if he comes with me is our best
shot at winning and i think we can do
this and he said we'll cover his whole
ticket go in
and we we won when armada plays the
platforms hbox is all over him i think
that is it congratulations to hungrybox
making history here on european soil
we did it dude i mean just like that's
that's it's trust right and it's that
level of trust that steve and i have had
in each other that has allowed me to i
think get to the point that i have and
that's really what matters within the
team is trust and ability to make these
decisions as melee had risen in
prominence it had earned a spot among
fighting games as greatest at evo
previously hbox had fallen just short in
both 2014 and 2015. an evo 2016 win
would cement both his and liquid's
legacy in the esport armada not giving
him anything
he gets back that could be it
theresa
[Applause]
it gives you affirmation in your own
self you look at your hands after you
won you look at the lights and sounds
and you said like man i really dreamed
about this i really envisioned this
being what happens to me and i put all
my energy and time into doing it and i
finally [ __ ] made it but while
hungrybox was putting his and liquid's
name on melee trophies the organization
was expanding too they added a cs go
team by signing the former denial
esports roster in 2015. by 2016 it
featured some of the names that would
help the roster explode onto the scene
including elige for an organization as
old as liquid was this signing was a
milestone of sorts elige who had played
starcraft and followed the esport didn't
just see a prospective employer in
liquid he had grown up as a fan when i
first joined liquid it was definitely
like the team that i've always admired
the most like throughout like my esports
career like uh and by career i mean just
like when i was gaming growing up
because of starcraft 2 and everything
but liquid was finding new fans too part
of that was steve's willingness to enter
the spotlight we're gonna see how this
looks tomorrow in the sunlight and of
course talk about liquid sponsors
sorry my htc phone is ringing
well that's
sometimes it happens part of it was the
team's dramatic breaking point
documentary offering a candid unfiltered
and frankly sometimes shocking look
inside the league of legends roster
which had struggled to find consistent
results the coaching staff doesn't want
to work with you
they feel like it's a really
unprofessional unhealthy work
environment it was kind of interesting
because it was like even when we weren't
winning we were relevant
you know it was like uh you'd log on to
the league of legends reddit and
people were talking about breaking point
we had a kind of a duality with our
strategy
associated with maintaining relevancy
within league and contributing to
provide content to fans a massive sale
of the company's controlling interest to
axiomatic in late 2016 meant liquid had
more resources than ever but as liquid
saw growth added new teams and signed
promising players matters were coming to
a head in both league of legends and
dota 2.
on august 12 2017 liquid's league of
legends team would face phoenix one for
the right to remain in the lcs when we
were in promotion relegation and we had
our backs against the wall we were
playing in those matches if we would
have lost them we would have been kicked
out of the league and we wanted to fight
our way back in
and it would have cost the organization
millions of dollars right plus whatever
kind of brand damage was associated with
that and on that exact same day august
12th another one of their teams in one
of the org's oldest disciplines was
fighting for an opportunity to compete
for esports's biggest prize
[Applause]
it was this unlikely blend a chance to
find ultimate glory at exactly the same
moment in time that the team needed to
ward off a potentially costly and
humiliating defeat steve was with the
league of legends team while nazgul was
at the international's grand finals we
were playing our promotion relegation
matches and they were so close can they
pick them off and they will the knockout
for dardoch and they're all dead it's
gonna be the eighth it's gonna be the
game and it's the match tl back-to-back
bo5's win of the promotion tournament
and i remember being in the room in the
back and there was this feeling of
relief
and then
i think it might have been 30 minutes
later we won the international
[Applause]
in a single day the league of legends
roster had saved the organization
millions while the dota 2 roster had
earned millions from a record
24.7 million dollar prize pool i would
actually say like when we won
international and and stayed in the lcs
i feel like that was the day where i
would say we firmly established
ourselves as an absolute tier one
organization within esports especially
if you look at the fact that stargardt
had been on the decline right you can
argue that we were tier one in like 2010
2011. um but as far as i know there's
not really any organizations that have
their roots in starcraft that are around
uh
right now at the top of esports anymore
and sure starcraft might have been in
its twilight years but other games were
stepping up as the score esports broke
the story about the impending league of
legends franchising model previously
only hinted at by riot teams were
already lining up to apply for their
spot and 2018 saw liquid earn a spot in
the newly franchised nalcs after
submitting an exhaustive application one
that famously included a biographical
section about steve's life among other
things
yeah that was a small section but it was
you know a section on how we're going to
create apparel what is our roster going
to be how are we going to create content
how are we going to
have a
distinctive brand within lcs how are we
going to grow our fan base how are we
going to grow the team over the next
five years you know it was literally
five books each book being about 30
pages layout and design with graphics
and illustrations and charts and writing
and that was our
league of legends business plan it was a
huge win for liquid in an esport they
had committed to and their success
didn't stop there bringing back
doublelift the ad carry whom steve
actually played with years prior they
became back to back nalcs champions in
2018 and then tacked on another two in
2019 to win four in a row they are the
only team to lift the trophy back to
back to back to back and they are the
best team north america has ever
produced but liquid wasn't done taking
new risks and this time it would take
them to a whole new continent
[Music]
rainbow six siege hadn't exactly gotten
off to a great start but by 2018 it was
clear the game was deep competitive and
here to stay liquid wanted a piece of
that action but it wasn't obvious who
they would sign the league of legends
and cs go teams were north american the
dota 2 team was a mix from europe and
asia and those original liquid brood war
players had been from the netherlands so
liquid decided to step into one of the
most exciting regions and not just
rainbow six but esports as a whole
brazil after winning pro league season 7
finals in 2018 the team became a
consistent top 10 contender in the world
featuring explosive and aggressive
gameplay backed up by superstars like
nesc push from liquid in the back
penguin will get taken down a sexy kick
rushes in and there's just still more
candelas being shot in jonas cannot see
a single thing as that gets through more
on the board here but more than that the
rainbow six team started a relationship
that has continued to the present day
that's what we're really excited about i
was actually just on a presentation this
morning talking about our new facility
that we're going to be opening up in
brazil and how large it's going to be
and how many people are going to be
there and what we're going to do with
that space but even with that new
relationship north american cs fans were
looking to liquid for a win after a
tumultuous period where the roster
featured ukrainian phenom simple they
had gone back to basics and in 2019 the
roster was red-hot he's got the c-set
and he's gone it's all on the jw smoked
away and it's done finally
finally liquid get their notch on the
grand slam
and stewie is the answer it turns out
after all in their sights was the intel
grand slam a million dollar prize for
winning four premier tournaments
organized by esl or dreamhack masters
during a ten event window the only team
to have done it was astralis the danish
powerhouse who won a total of four major
titles together it was astralis that
drew first blood in the second grand
slam season but liquid fired back taking
three more against a new class of teens
that were looking to become the next
dominant contender a two versus two and
liquid have the advantage they're trying
to bring it down to the two versus one
if it's rpk this drop they could be in
serious trouble that should do it there
we go it's team liquid and that's what
it means to them they've taken it at the
fourth map the favorites coming into the
tournament have just unlocked the intel
grand slam at esl one cologne under the
belt and a million dollar bonus
that's something that was always really
cool to me about our grand slam win was
that we were just beating random teams
we weren't just winning small events we
were winning big events against the best
teams in the world and we finished it
off at cologne where all of the best
teams in the world were there liquid did
something improbable with this grand
slam win but the team's success
especially as play went online in 2020
wasn't to last a three versus five to
keep liquid in this and it's not
happening these two snipers have made a
world of difference and now vinnie's
looking to lock it down a minute on the
clock for naf he runs desperately in and
furious qualified still as they stayed
at the orcs facility in the netherlands
the team got what they needed to remain
calm in a rapidly changing world so we
pretty much always had really good
options like if we ever thought that
something was necessary
infrastructure-wise or like a boot camp
then liquid has gotten it and it's only
gotten better with uh the office that we
have now in the netherlands which is
made dealing with coven and all the
travel that we've had to do in the past
uh two years now a lot more manageable
the facility is incredible we have chefs
that are full-time that are providing us
two three meals a day and that just
relieves a lot of the stress that i
think that a lot of other teams probably
have on them when they're traveling and
speaking of changing worlds the
landscape of tactical fps games like
counter-strike was about to shift with
the release of riots project a now
renamed to valorant again the new game
brought on a feeding frenzy and by now
liquid was so big that they would
clearly be angling for a spot they
signed a promising lineup featuring
names like scream and would later add
his brother navera and csgo outcast
yampi while they fell short of a masters
or champions victory they earned top
four at two s-tier tournaments in 2021
but their european roster wasn't the end
with riot showing that they wanted to
offer more opportunities for women and
non-binary people liquid signed a
brazilian women's roster further
deepening their connections to the
country liquid wasn't just hopping on
the hot new thing they were trying to
rethink old ones too signing top wow
guild limit
wait chill chill chill chill
[Music]
let's go
[Applause]
what the limit uh now liquid
folks do i mean that is mastery at it at
its finest um so
that actually fits perfectly and then
together with like the fantasy world
approach of mmos like
that is gonna be a massive uh massive
initiative for us and while their league
of legends roster had fallen short of
international success the lineup now
assembled for 2022 included bjergsen
tsm's perennial superstar now playing
mid for liquid sometimes when i'm trying
to look up are after we play a match and
i'm trying to like watch the game on
youtube i'll write like oh tsm vs 100
thieves and then i'm like where's the
game
i can't find the game and i'm like oh
yeah i wanted liquid now the new lineup
attracted some discussion given that
they play in a north american league but
residency rules have allowed them to
field what is essentially an
international roster but for liquid
their international identity is a
byproduct of a strategy that seeks to
achieve international success you owe it
to the other players that are on that
roster you owe it to your fans who you
have said winning is important to build
the best absolute roster that you
possibly can
given whatever rules or constraints
there are on the league and so that's
what we do every year we approach the
offseason with a massive spreadsheet of
all the potential players that are
available around the world and we
determine what is the right mix in order
to build a roster to win to do well at
worlds to represent north america at
worlds but there's one more thing to
discuss about liquid in 2021 they
extended an offer to some of their
longest tenured players to become part
owners of the team i think steve was
willing to give myself and of course the
other couple of athletes that were able
to have the opportunity he really wanted
to
showcase the opportunity for growth of
players within the org but he also
wanted us to be i think bigger parts
because he knew of our experience and he
knew the input that we had was kind of
invaluable to the scenes in which we
represent team liquid didn't start as a
pitch to investors or a logo in a
marketing deck sure in 2022 it's a
business and it certainly deals with
those things now but there's something
about knowing that the team you cheer
for is run by people who understand the
feeling when you take over a game the
feeling when you achieve something
impossible they started off chasing
those feelings too and that's why being
a liquid fan feels different because
whether you're one of the five gods or a
fan cheering your heart out you get back
what you put in and that's what liquid
is about
thanks for watching if you want more
content like this then hit the sub
button and ring the notification bell
for unique bite size videos you won't
find anywhere else hit up our twitter
instagram facebook and tick tock
[Music]